previously on TV sins but you know the
business and I know the chemistry you
had me at hello the game they say a
person either has what it takes to play
or they don't my mother was one of the
greats
main characters parent was a legend at
whatever career they are trying to
succeed at and will have many obstacles
to overcome cliche also an immigration
me on the other hand I'm kind of screwed
well considering you're both naked with
clothing strewn around you I'm not
exactly sure you need the kinda in there
at all main character has a one-night
stand with one of her bosses before
realizing it's one of the bosses cliche
it's gonna be a lot of these so I'm just
gonna tack on ten sins for all the soap
opera cliche bullsh I'm gonna have to
wait through left on where you left off
did you fall asleep during sex did you
call in time out for some R&R
did you only get through 30 shades of
dr. gray and figured you'd get to the
other twenty later three consecutive
different shots of the Space Needle we
get it show it's located in Seattle you
Space Needle me anymore it end up with
track marks in my arms the seven years
you spend here as a surgical resident
will be the best and worst of your life
oh cool show sets up a narrative
structure for seven seasons thank God
it's not one of those shows that will
out stay it's welcome and go on for 15
plus seasons but that will never happen
this is your starting line this is your
arena why is it in TV shows that all
jobs start off with a rousing speech
from a supervisor the last job I took
they walked me to my cubicle pointed to
where the restrooms were and never once
even made eye contact 20 yeah here one
of them is a model it's a network
television show pretty sure all six or
models we met at that the mixer you had
on a black dress of the beside strappy
sandals and now you think I'm gay that's
greatest that's the Nazi that's the Nazi
big guy I thought the Nazi would be
that's if you've been playing the Grey's
Anatomy Nazi drinking game you are now
suffering from a severe case of alcohol
poisoning run labs write orders work
every second night until you drop and
don't complain show was doing so much
walk and talk I swear it's trying
desperately to make me think Aaron
Sorkin wrote it except somehow it might
actually be good enough to live up to
the comparison oh the Shonda Rhimes
person gets more work down the line she
seems like a real up-and-comer is he
seems to suffer from a case of
disappearing glasses a large-bore IV
don't let the blood hemolyzed let's go I
wanted to give some bonus points for at
least
let's go instead of Stamp but this is
still the same shout medical jargon the
audience probably doesn't understand
kick that medical shows have been doing
since Jesus Christ starting Bethlehem 9
1 1 mmm show me now I wish I could but
I'm a healer you and I are gonna have so
much fun together could work in or with
my bare hands
well technically could work in ended
lives of patients who wanted to die on
their own terms so since you would be
murdering her you'd actually be Harold
Shipman appear hands but semantics right
george'll Mallon me you'll scrub in for
an appendectomy this afternoon not sure
why this would surprise anyone George is
the only person Burke has spent any time
with dr. Shephard we should pretend it
never happens parents having questions
right
that probably trumps embarrassment over
one night stand with pseudo balls last
night my size sorry come okay my red
shirt on my good-looking shirt you took
advantage was Patrick Dempsey's goal in
life to be discount Rob Lowe because he
couldn't sound any more like him if he
were butchering CCR's problem area in an
Oscar ceremony and yes I actually wrote
this sin before I knew that Rob Lowe
turned down this role before Dempsey
took it dr. Shepherd yes is it
appropriate indeed it is and yet the
show wants us to think it's adorable
because they needed to become the
central relationship to the show and for
us to like both of these characters yeah
Shepherds being a dick here and no
amount of charm is gonna change my mind
here okay the nurse phage me 9-1-1 I
don't go all Exorcist to get her to even
pick up the phone so why would the nurse
paid 911 if she knew the patient was
fine Meredith's anger should really be
more directed at the nurse in this
situation but I can't sleep my head's
awful
that's called thinking go with it and
that's when grey and her entire Anatomy
would have been fired real doctors tend
to do this thing called maintaining
professionalism I'll page him again stat
stat and you were doing so well
the patient is descending into cliche
ptosis we need 10 cc's of Synod all stat
we came here because this hospital is
supposed to be the best in Washington
she was life flighted though right so
she was going wherever was the closest
so I shouldn't worry I'm very good at
what I do
Oh shadowing she's all just freaking
ancient just lucky she's still breathing
I got a shot to scrub in downstairs and
a patient wasn't alive during
Civil War don't page me again geez does
this guy work in the proctology wing
because he is an [ __ ] doctor for sure
don't worry though he's sure to get his
comeuppance here real soon because TVs
got a TV you know what is just make
gymnastics I don't never I can't even
say it I don't know what it did and of
course the medical shoe light bulb goes
off as they talk about something
seemingly unrelated to the case just
once I want a doctor in one of these
shows to figure something out because of
studied knowledge or expertise instead
of randomly backdooring their way into a
surprising climax Hey
phrasing in an environment where every
second counts there is no way these
elevator door shenanigans continue to
happen how did they get in the elevator
or he steps out but this is the kind of
nonsense that gets you disbarred or
discredit ghost or something
I've been on enough elevators to know if
the door closes all the way for that
long you are already on your way to a
new floor unless this one was built with
a dramatic tension door release system
then I guess it's possible I wouldn't
dare play it but this episode is full of
dated music that is very distinctly 2005
I didn't even know music could beat
distinctly 2005 and yep
you're young you're important enough to
make promises to mr. savage you get to
be the one to tell him that she's a
widow like hell he is so you're telling
me that hospitals would have
inexperienced newb delivering that kind
of news just to make a point there are
two possibilities here either this show
is an extremely exaggerated take on
hospital personalities four hospitals
have a lot less care for their patients
families than I thought either way the
sim doctor has arrived and he's already
scrubbed in also I get the perks man but
considering how little faith he has in
gorge to be able to do anything does
this seem like a good idea I wish I
wanted to be a chef or a ski instructor
or a kindergarten teacher or a baller
shot caller wind water wound walking
wander drugs someone saw a different
version of the fifth element than I did
also why is it that this hospital is
full of extremely busy people until the
moment our hero needs to one-up the
resident [ __ ]
and then all of a sudden an entire room
of medical personnel can stop in a watch
do exactly as she says then tell your
resident that I want you off this case
and of course dr. douche pickle here
gets put in his place and it's not just
this plot line that seems obvious the
show foreshadowed so hardcore that I
knew huh every one of these stories
would resolve the show Telegraph's its
resolution so much it's like it works
for Western Union you practice on
cadavers you observe and you think you
know what you're gonna feel like
standing over that table but that was
such a high this is also the exact same
thing a serial killer would say so
I made it through my first shift and
there was freaking narration at the end
as well what is this a CW DC show oh and
also skip I'm gonna help you forget that
you'll soon be dead okay so I'm just
gonna insert my fingers into your
fractal rectum damn near kill go I do
read make gymnastics which is like
really cool nobody else does it and in
conclusion may I please remind you that
it does not say RSVP on the Statue of
Liberty he's choking come on George
today put your balls on your butt pucker
let's go we can't have anyone freak out
out there okay we've gotta keep our
composure we can spend all day arguing
right or wrong give me the hundred bucks
we didn't bet we could spend all day
arguing with me better not give me the
hundred bucks it takes a steady hand
because if you touch the side that I am
a doctor doctor doctor doctor doctor
doctor doctor